the one wolf alive and the sheep are
never safe
this is the second end last time Arya
Stark actually uses a face to be an
assassin feels bad man staying off the
kingsroad are you they get you no matter
where you go you can't win so the reason
why I'm showing you this clip is that
one person randomly in a forest spots
Jaime and Brienne and it leads to their
immediate capture through the man
telling the Bolton's about Jaime less
all right in season 7 however not a
single person in Westeros saw the
biggest fleet of ships in the world this
also isn't the first time that this
happens literally the episode prior the
Greyjoy's gets surprise attacked as if
the iron fleet has a 100 and stealth
these aren't some ships not even Varys
who's supposed to know everything didn't
even know about the fleet's whereabouts
but in season two he always knew her
Stannis's fleet was where are their
ships it is wise to attack you might
surprise what Varys knows what you had
for breakfast three days ago there are
no surprises here it is wise to attack
at night with my surprise Varys in
season seven and a basically turns into
a passive character and he essentially
does nothing you need to find a way to
make her listen the second he takes
action in season eight he just dies Jon
Snow voices bunty's amazes Marika vo
Dora Lara's Ozma Hagen contas the Prince
he was promised we'll bring the doom
yeah that didn't really come back up in
the story I am NOT here to be queen of
the ashes
[Music]
what are you doing no one can see us
like this I am The Queen of the Seven
Kingdoms I'll do as I please so sir
she's okay now about people knowing that
she's having sex with her brother but
thing still gets mad at them for
acknowledging it and the Kings there you
enjoy risking your neck don't you your
grace he's already destroyed a good
portion of our fleet to send our
remaining ships after I'm not talking
about sending our ships after him they
can still do something to you it only
takes one arrow it's too great a risk
you're too important it feels like this
was only done so they could keep the
iron food alive long enough in season
eight so that they can kill regal I can
never be Lord of Winterfell I can never
be Lord of anything and the three-eyed
Raven I don't think she'll come see the
dead at my invitation so bring the dead
to her I thought that was what we were
trying to avoid we don't have to bring
the whole army new one soldier as
everyone has pointed out this is the
worst idea possible a much better plan
would be to try to get in contact with
benjin given his half-turned
and can inform everyone in Westeros
about the night King his only purpose
was the safe people and David and Dan
just don't know what to do with them
this would actually give us character
meaning instead of being an ex machina
French huh
all right gotta pass come with me this
general point also goes into the outcome
of the season the entire meeting in
King's Landing is pointless because
Cersei just doesn't end up helping
anyone
this waste about like 40 minutes of our
time in an already rushed season it was
also like three episodes of build-up and
all we get is Jaime Lannister the only
reason any of this happened was that the
night king could obviously acquire a
dragon that's why a lot of the
characters act stupidly like this case
for instance
[Music]
I also don't get why in the scene that
the Nike doesn't just go for drogon he's
sitting still in all of his main
competition in terms of characters are
just sitting there on him like why not
so they kill the white walker in this
group and all the other whites die
except this one that's oddly convenient
get a raven to Daenerys tell her what's
happened I'm not leaving you
you're the fastest go now
three hours later my name is Barry Allen
and I am the fastest man alive
and she also hasn't been in the snow
before so this must be a miracle that
he's ran this far this is what makes a
white boy on the ice a rock not the
night keen commanding him to maybe he is
commanding him but it's not clear also
how is the ice not breaking right now
there's so many whites on the ice I love
having the scene that this x-ray gets
tackled by bunch of white sand barracks
at Sidney axe home he's like uh he's an
extra he's on the main character I'm not
gonna save him I could also go into how
devoid of logic the plot armor of these
characters are like how tournaments
should definitely be dead in the scene
but I'd be repeating similar points as
in Game of Thrones but it's full pot
armor so I'll just put that video in the
end screen and in the description
I just want both to protect you and your
sister if I abandon dream to King's
Landing is long lady Brienne and you
won't be travelling on summer roads soon
you leave the better your chances of
making it on time yes my lady
so for the final point of the video
we're going to look at the whole
situation with Littlefinger in this
season there's a lot of drama between
Sansa and Arya and how Littlefinger's
manipulating them the whole time the
thing that does not make sense is why
bran did not tell Arya and Sansa
immediately about Littlefinger's
misdoings like he obviously knows but he
just doesn't tell anyone till the end of
the season thank you for all your many
lessons Lord Baelish
I will never forget them
[Music]
also Aria kills Littlefinger so that
means she can use his face and
impersonate him he's a very powerful
person and I don't know why she wouldn't
want to use his face she can gain so
much from it and the only person she
uses his Walder Frey but yeah those are
most of the main points that I
remembered while we watching the season
you guys really elected the Board of
logic series for Season eight and so I
wanted to make this one - although it's
very very late hopefully you guys
enjoyed it and have a nice day